Thought I'd start by just letting you
know why I was objecting specifically to
build see 16.
Um,
I made three videos in
late September and uh,
one of them criticized [inaudible] 16
and one of them criticize the University
of Toronto Administrations,
the human resources peoples decision
to make so called anti unconscious anti
bias training mandatory
for their HR staff,
which I thought was and still
think was reprehensible.
And uh,
I don't even remember what
the other one was about,
but it doesn't really matter.
Those were,
that was the first one.
The one on bill see 16 that caused
most of the fewer surprisingly enough.
And I said I wouldn't use the made up.
What I consider neologisms that
purport to describe the status,
the status of people whose sexual identity
is ambiguous because that isn't how
it looked to me.
It looked to me like these words
like z and Zurr and so forth were the
linguistic vanguard of a intellectual
movement that I would say detest is
probably the right
description.
And that's this strange
blend of postmodernism and
Marxism that has emerged to
occupy the bulk of the humanities.
And a good chunk of the social sciences.
And so that was the first thing
is that I'm not using those words.
That was the first
thing that was personal,
right?
Is that that's not a form of linguistic
game that I'm willing to play.
And I have my reasons for that.
The second was I regard the ledge.
Any legislation that compels people to
use a certain kind of language as a very
dangerous,
first of all,
dangerous piece of legislation directly,
but also a very dangerous precedent.
I mean,
there are limits on free speech that are
already reasonably well instantiated in
the law.
You can't incite a crime,
you can't threaten someone
bodily in a believable manner.
You can't libel someone we already
have reasonable restrictions on,
on what you can't say.
But we've never had legislation that
required you to use a certain language
except in certain commercial applications.
So for example,
if you sell tobacco,
you have to put a warning on it.
But the United States
Supreme Court decided,
I believe it was in the 1940s that
similar attempts to compel speech,
uh,
on the part of individuals
in noncommercial settings
was unconstitutional.
And,
and uh,
I know that that doesn't have any direct
bearing on Canadian law but certainly
the principal does.
And then I was also very see one of the
problems with a piece of legislation,
and this is,
I suppose the problem with interpreting
a text as the postmodernists would say,
is that it's not easy to get the
level of interpretation right?
Right.
Cause if you're interpreting a text,
you can look at them,
you can look at the letters that
happens with biblical interpretation.
Very often you'd look
at the individual words,
you can look at the phrases,
you're going to get the sentences,
you can look at the paragraphs,
you could look at the work as a whole.
And then you also have to look at the
context within which the work is being
interpreted in order to come up with
an interpretation of anything that's
complex.
And so when you see a
piece of legislation,
it isn't obvious what the legislation
is actually intended to do despite what
it's purported to do.
And it isn't obvious what level of
analysis to pick when you're going to
criticize it.
And in some ways bill see 16,
you could regard it as innocuous just
as an extension of rights that have
already been granted to certain,
let's say protected groups.
Although I'm not so thrilled about the
whole notion of ascribing rights to
groups to begin with.
We're already far down that path.
But,
um,
and you know,
I've been accused of making a
mountain out of a mole hill,
but happily enough,
the University of Toronto,
after I made the videos,
immediately produced two letters that
were informed by their legal departments
wisdom,
um,
stating that what I had done with the
video was perhaps in conflict with the
university ethical guidelines.
If you forget the ones that had to do
with freedom of expression and that they
might,
that my actions and even in making
the video might have violated that the
tenants of the Ontario Human Rights
Act as its or the at least as it's
interpreted by the Ontario
Human Rights Commission.
And so that helped put to
rest any suggestion that I
was actually scaremongering
because as soon as I,
as soon as I made the videos,
the legal department at the UFT
immediately validated my fears.
And so that was a perverse,
was a perverse effect of their,
of the letters they sent to me.
So,
um,
the other thing that I,
there was other elements
of the legislation that I
object to and objected to and
still do.
And if you read the policies within which
the legislation will be interpreted as
the federal justice,
uh,
website indicated that it
would be interpreted in
within the policies that the
Ontario Human Rights Commission
has already established.
Of course there's close cross talk
between Ontario and the federal government
because the liberals are in power in both.
And the radical end of the liberal
party's in power in both situations.
And know it turns out that it's illegal
for like a year liable as an employer.
For example,
if any of your employees say anything
that can be construed as harassment,
say on the grounds of sexual,
uh,
or gender identity,
even if what they say has
unintended consequences.
And even if you don't
know that they said it.
And so that kind of legislation I just
think is just absolutely reprehensible.
And then because it's designed to cast
the broadest possible net to catch the
most fish,
and it's clearly,
uh,
being implemented by people who
are not precisely pro employer,
let's put it that way.
And then there's another little ugly
secret hidden underneath the policies.
And that's manifest most clearly in the
form of what's come to be known as the
Gender Unicorn,
which I would recommend that you look up,
which is an animated character designed
to indoctrinate small children into the
social constructionist worldview,
which claims that biological sex,
gender identity,
gender expression and sexual
proclivity very independently,
which they most certainly do not now.
And that's what I said in the video.
That's partly why I've
been accused of say,
being a transphobic.
I also complained that the university
was taking policy advice from,
uh,
the people who started black lives matter.
And I don't have anything against
black lives matter particularly,
but the two people who started it are,
are not,
uh,
the sorts of individuals let's say that
the university should be basing its
policy decisions,
the advice they shouldn't be taking
advice from those people with regards to
their policy.
And apparently that makes me a racist.
So,
um,
the first part of the argument about
what happened with my videos was actually
whether or not I was racist and
Trans phobic and all of that.
But the point that I was
making the technical specific
technical point was that
the claim that,
uh,
those four phenomena very
independently was just patently false.
And it is by any reasonable
definition of false.
And I know that it's part
of a much broader propaganda
exercise as evidenced by
the Gender Unicorn for example,
which gets children to indicate on four
sliders their sex assigned at birth,
their gender identity,
their gender expression and
their sexual proclivity.
And you can look at the animation or
at the at the cartoon and decide for
yourself by its graphic style
what people it's aimed at.
So,
um,
is this a bill to protect transsexual
rights or is it a bill to further a
postmodern neo Marxist agenda?
Well God only knows but as far as I'm
concerned having analyze the context
within which this bill arose and
within which it will be interpreted,
I'm going to go for the furthering the
postmodern Neil Marxist agenda until I'm,
until that's thoroughly disproved.
I would also like to inform you that I've
had plenty of letters from transgender
people,
at least 30 and only one of
them was critical of what
I'm doing because they had
claim and as,
as have many of the people I've talked
to that the idea that a group of
activists self can self nominate as
the representatives of a given group.
And then speak for them as if they have
a homogenous voice is absolutely absurd.
And it is.
It is completely ridiculous.
And most of the transsexual people that
have been contacting me have said the
same thing,
which is these people don't speak for me.
I wish they'd shut up cause they're doing
a lot more harm than good and I don't
buy what they're doing anyways.
So,
you know,
I think that the claim of the activist
types to speak on behalf of the groups
that they purport to
represent is weak at best.
And I don't know why we ever assume that,
that their representation is valid,
except that we're afraid to criticize
that particular presupposition.
You know,
I mean,
there's nothing more ridiculous
than assuming that someone
is because someone is
black that they speak for black people.
I mean,
I think,
I can't think of anything that's more
particularly indicative of a fundamentally
racist attitude than that.
You know?
Well those people,
they're all the same.
It's like,
yeah,
well,
sorry,
it doesn't work out that way.
So I wanted to clarify
all that so that you know,
you have a little bit clearer idea about
why I was doing what I was doing and
people have asked so to speak,
why I chose to die on
that particular hale.
And the answer is every,
every massive conflict of ideas let's
say manifests itself in the minute.
And that's why it's often difficult to
gain any headway because no matter where
you draw the line,
it's arbitrary and,
and subject to criticism.
And you know,
the fact that this happens to be about
gender neutral pronouns regarding
transgender people to me is
just more or less an accident.
It could have been about almost
any number of other things and,
but I would also like to suggest that
what should have happened with what I did
was nothing.
Right?
I made some videos that were relatively
obscure academic and I made some videos
in my private time that were,
you know,
pretty badly produced
because they're just amateur.
And I was trying to straighten out
my thinking about a couple of issues,
the anti unconscious bias training,
for example,
and also this legislative mass.
And obviously it struck a major chord.
And that to me is indication that my
original supposition was correct and that
there was far more going on under the
surface than there was at the surface.
I mean,
you know,
like I said,
it's very difficult to pick
the proper level of analysis,
but one of the ways you justify your
choices by observing the impact of your
choice of level of analysis
and seeing if it's,
if the consequences are commensurate
with your original hypothesis.
And I thought,
well,
just because people say they're doing
one thing with a piece of legislation
doesn't mean that that's
what they're doing.
And of course,
I led piece of legislation is a hydra.
In any case,
it does all sorts of things that
people don't intend it to do.
So that's a little background and
I'll leave the background at that.